as temperatures plunge the war in
Ukraine is entering a new and brutal
phase Russia's attacks on critical
infrastructure amount to weaponizing
Winter as Ukrainian civilians shelter
and bombed out houses without power and
water and soldiers in flooded trenches
face heavy shelling what will it take
for one side or the other to gain
Advantage as fighting slows and
conditions worsen we're asking Russia
versus Ukraine who's better equipped for
the winter War
thank you
[Music]
welcome to to the point it is a pleasure
to greet our guests Nico langa is senior
fellow at the Munich security conference
and was previously chief of the
executive staff at the German defense
Ministry also a pleasure to welcome
Thomas vigold he is a military expert
and a freelance journalist with a
popular blog covering security affairs
and joining us virtually from London is
ulrika Franco of the European Council on
Foreign Relations actually currently
joining us from France
I'd like to begin if I may with you
Thomas and in history winter has
famously worked to Russia's Advantage
helping them repel Napoleon Hitler would
you say winter will also help the
Russians this time well I doubted this
time because we have to see yes Russia
had an advantage against Napoleon
against the Germans in second world war
on the other hand if you remember the
Finnish winter war in 1939 it was a
different story and the Finns had the
advantage because they knew the terrain
the new winter they knew how to deal
with it and here we have the ukrainians
who also have an advantage because they
know the terrain and they know the
situation so this old equation Russia
knows how to win a winter War wouldn't
necessarily apply at this point what are
the two key factors if you had to
identify just two what are the two key
factors that essentially decide who has
the advantage under harsh conditions
well one obviously is equipment who had
the better winter kit we're talking
about clothing here just simple things
like cold weather gear jackets trousers
all the stuff you can buy and the other
point is something you can't buy that's
morale the fighting morale of the
Ukrainian seems quite different from the
Russians because you have Ukrainian
troops fighting for their Homeland while
on the other hand you have Russians who
have been conscripted partially into
this war or fighting on a foreign front
who are not fighting for their Homeland
and it's quite a difference and we want
to come back to talk a bit more about
morale later on but Nico President Putin
is warning now that the war could be I
quote a lengthy process meaning clearly
if he's not seeing Russia backing down
anytime soon does that mean that this
winter will simply freeze things in
place literally and figuratively or
could it in fact prove decisive for the
outcome
we are in a lengthy War already
which means that also the industrial
aspects of supporting the war become
more important and I think that is what
Putin is hinting at he thinks he can
outproduce us
but when it comes to the winter I
personally believe fighting will
continue
and to Historic pictures we have in mind
about winter War they are not appliable
applicable to this war in Ukraine the
Black Sea Coast is not Siberia
and even if it is cold for example
Ukraine has a lot of vehicles on Wheels
they will get more mobile when the
ground is frozen so we might even see
more activity because I think Ukraine is
trying to use the advantage it has and
use the momentum further even in Winter
very interesting Eureka if equipment and
morale are the two crucial factors that
would seem to favor Ukraine in fact as
uh as we heard but is there reason to
doubt that that might be the case going
forward apparently Russian Air transport
planes have been seen making repeated
trips to China and there's speculation
that they are picking up gear and
equipment for Russian soldiers could
that change the calculus here
hmm yeah it is quite difficult to tell
what's going on in Russia there um the
situation of course is that Ukraine gets
a lot of support from the west and
Russia and has fewer friends in the
world but we've already seen with
support from Iran and Iranian drones and
the like um support from North Korea
Belarus and now potentially China that
this could could make a difference
um that being said I think in terms of
equipment as long as as the support from
the the West continuous Ukraine can have
an advantage um here but it is overall
relatively difficult to tell kind of how
deep Russian stocks are and how much
they could get from elsewhere
one thing is certainly clear conditions
will get worse before they get better
rain and mud will give way to snow and
ice slowing down operations rendering
both soldiers and civilians vulnerable
to cold and hunger let's take a closer
look at what that means for Ukrainian
morale so far
fight in freezing temperature
soldiers on both sides suffer from heavy
shelling while also fighting against
hunger cold and moisture
the suffering of the civilian population
in Ukraine is comparable they're
Sheltering in bombed out houses and
apartments but the will to preserve
seems Unbroken
it is better to suffer a cold winter to
freeze and starve as long as the
Russians aren't here
the Russian bombings often cause water
electric and heating shortages
the enemy wants to use winter against us
to use cold and deprivation as a means
of Terror
we have to do everything to survive this
winter no matter how hard it will be
the Russian army is still blasting away
with all the fighter bombers and
helicopters at their disposal but
Western intelligence Services predict
that winter will bring more quiet to the
front a time for both sides to procure
weapons and ammunition for the spring
who will be more resilient this winter
Russians or ukrainians
let me pass that question uh directly to
Nico and certainly we heard grit and
determination there in those statements
from people in Ukraine but kiev's mayor
has just been warning of an apocalypse
if Russian shelling of Civilian
infrastructure continues as it as it has
what would that civilian suffering mean
for the morale of the troops
well first of all the resilience of the
Ukrainian population is just amazing it
is outstanding also the networks of
ukrainians who are improvising at the
moment to sustain the temperatures in
the big cities in Ukraine I think that
is a great strength of ukrainians that
also can Inspire us but um I think we
should take seriously what vitally
Klitschko is saying what also the bosses
of the Ukrainian energy companies are
saying that the repairs might not be
possible quickly and that there might at
least temporarily the need be the need
to evacuate parts of the population to
have them safely there over winter
especially elderly and and children
um in terms of the front lines I think
it doesn't change change much
the Ukrainian Armed Forces they are
experienced in Winter the war started in
Winter we should not forget that they
have built their fortifications and it
seems to me that they are also more
disciplined and winter War when it comes
to soldiers fighting is very much about
discipline of keeping your dry kit from
your wet kit of having your
fortifications clean and without water
and to me it seems Ukrainian ukrainians
have a Advantage there that is also
connected to the morale uh that has been
mentioned and also I think Ukraine wants
to push further this winter they do not
want to lose time they want to push the
Russians out of their territory so they
will use also the winter for that thank
you Rica shelling is far from the only
weapon of Civilian intimidation that
Putin has been deploying a U.N report
documents a whole array of war crimes
including torture rape abusive children
what impact is that likely to have on
morale in Ukraine and of course this
isn't new that these tactics are being
used what's the historic uh record do
they work as those who deploy them in
Hope
um I think all these atrocities that
that we're hearing um about
um just reminds European uh sorry
Ukrainian soldiers what they're fighting
for that you really cannot leave
territory and whereas if the Ukrainian
population under Russian occupation so I
think in a way it it reinforces the the
will of all ukrainians to fight but of
course you know these are terrible and
horrible attractives uh we also I mean
this as you said this has a long history
and Russia in particular has used these
types of weaponizing the winter the cold
hunger especially in Ukraine in in the
past we know this this well but yeah I
mean overall it it does reinforce I
think the the will to fight we've just
seen in the clip that you showed earlier
this woman who said you know we can
starve and we can freeze but as long as
we aren't on the Russian occupation you
know know we're we're happy and this is
this is what we're fighting for
um but it depends on on how how bad it
gets and how many people might actually
die of you know cold
Thomas I'd be interested in your
thoughts on that point uh and then also
as well uh it's often said that Russia
could use the winter pause to regroup
and to recuperate from the pretty severe
losses that it has seen in recent months
uh can Ukraine do you think deny it that
chance well they can try I'm not sure if
they really can of course Russia will
use any pause in in the fighting to beef
up its strengths to transport material
to transport troops and whether Ukraine
really has a chance to deny them the
trend that's not true yet on the other
hand we've seen in recent days that
Ukraine was able to struck inside Russia
which means there's a shift still a
minor shift that but there might be a
shift not in the front line but but in
in the fighting so Ukraine might have
more chances than it for let me ask you
to talk a little bit more both of you in
the studio first of all about those
strikes because they were carried out by
drones and uh and as far as we know that
yeah
certainly this is now a full-scale drone
war is that right that's right we've
seen drones in in various sizes and in
all different uh tasking from the
cheapest stuff you can buy off of eBay
or whatever up to Old Soviet drones up
to mod a rather modern Iranian drones so
there's the full scale of unmanned
Warfare introduced in this war Orica the
Ukraine we think as we just said uh has
used drones to strike deep into Russian
territory both military airfields and a
refinery
is that do you think likely to provoke
escalation on the Russian side
Chancellor Schultz said this week that
he actually believes the risk of an
escalation and a nuclear strike has
decreased and this is something that is
of enormous concern to our viewers as we
can see from some of the comments that
are sent into our YouTube site so I'd be
curious about your assessment
hmm so I think the risk or the fear of
an escalation especially in nuclear
escalation is always there and needs to
be taken into consideration however I
mean first of all this isn't the first
time that Ukraine has struck within
Russian territory actually I think in
the first month of the war there was a
Ukrainian attack in Russian territory
which didn't lead to that kind of
escalation now this attack was closer to
the front line than the attacks in in
recent days but nevertheless and
similarly there were the attacks on the
the bridge to Crimea where also there
was a lot of speculation that this would
be the moment where Russia escalates
further and and it didn't
um it's it's difficult to tell because
in the end it is Putin who decides
whether or not and how to escalate but I
think what Ukraine really wanted to do
with these uh attacks in Russian
territory is to send a signal and a
signal to both Russia and the West the
signal to Russia is of course you know
if you start a a war you can't you know
this cannot be cost free and you can't
expect that this doesn't you know
influence you as well at home and we can
strike in your territory so that's an
important a signal and the other signal
was to the West um the West has been
somewhat reticent uh delivering systems
uh that can strike within Russian
territory exactly because of the sphere
of escalation and basically Ukraine is
now showing that they can do it with
their own equipment whether it's all
Soviet equipment as it has been
speculated or newly developed uh
equipment so there's this kind of
signaling in both directions through
these attacks but it is true again we we
aren't entirely we cannot be entirely
sure um with regard to the fear of
escalation but but what we're hearing
out of Russia at the moment
um I don't think that that this type of
escalation is is imminent Nico who has
the advantage uh in a drone Warfare is
it possible possible to to say when you
look at the two sides whether one or the
other essentially can use this to
Greater benefit and second question EU
sanctions are now aiming to choke off
Russia's access to drones would you
expect them to be able to do that
well first of all I agree with
everything that has been said that
drones are omnipresent in this war and
they are very often also used as a
support so it's not only a drone Warfare
I think it's a combination of low-tech
and high-tech that we are seeing and
even infantry soldiers would not move
forward I think on both sides without
having drones in the air
having reconnaissance about the area
difficult to say who has an advantage
but what we have seen is that ukrainians
were able to innovate during the war to
improvise to come up with new ideas and
that they are very good in using all the
digital possibilities that were there to
have a better understanding of the
situation and that helped them with
shaping their operations so I would see
a little advantage on the Ukrainian side
there I would even extend your point
about the sex sanctions
um
both sides are using a lot of Civilian
drones at the time I think it would be a
bold move to just to buy off all the
civilian drones from the market to give
them to Ukraine so that Russia cannot
get them I mean that would be the size
of the support that is needed the
um
drone Warfare has an aspect I think that
we also can learn from in NATO
uh the ukrainians are able to do things
that we are not capable of and that is
also something that should be looked
into
when we look at um
Ukraine's capacity Thomas they actually
have been known until now for Speed and
surprise we heard Nico say earlier that
he doesn't actually see the war slowing
down as much as some people seem to
predict I'd be curious whether you would
agree with that or whether you think
actually Ukraine will lose some of that
advantage that it has in the past I do
agree I think
the winter will not really have an
effect of course winter always slows
down operations
mud and all this stuff will slow down we
will see whether wheeled Vehicles will
have an advantage when the ground is
frozen how much tracked Vehicles will
have an impact Ukraine has both the
Russians have both
um
Russia has some problems with Logistics
when roads are closed so we'll see how
this works out my impression is Ukraine
is
a bit ahead on the other hand Russia has
vast stockpiles not only of ammunition
but also of old material so you might
say well it's an old truck or it's an
old tank but still if you have thousands
of those quantities making a difference
I think that's the main point Ukraine
has partially better material but
limited quantities and that's also a
question to the West how they can
replenish those quantities absolutely
and on the subject of yeah well I wanted
to go to limited quantities but in a
different area namely Munitions because
you have said Nico elsewhere that the
war could come down to a competition
over Munitions and we are seeing reports
including from U.S intelligence that
Russia is facing shortages of ammunition
so would you say that those are
confirmed and how does it play out that
some Western countries are also seeing
munition short images including this one
Germany what will that do in terms of
influencing the the the fighting Putin
seems to believe that he can outproduce
us not in all areas but in the area of
artillery ammunition that he is relying
on very much
and it is a question whether Ukraine is
using the material and ammunition faster
than the partners of Ukraine are
producing it Ukrainian defense industry
is destroyed through airstrikes and it
is on us to support Ukraine
and I think even the signal of scaling
up production capacities would already
send a communication to Putin that we
will do whatever is necessary and he
should not calculate that over time he
can gain the upper hand again I think
that is very important now so it's not
only the production of the ammunition
itself it's also the communication Visa
we put in and of course we have not been
ready for a full-scale war in Europe and
stockpiles have not been prepared I
think that's not only true for Germany I
think that's true for many countries and
I think we must uh just uh now
acknowledge that the idea of producing
everything just in time and then bring
it Mobility to places everywhere is not
compatible with Crisis Prevention and
with being prepared for a war and
disaster I think that's not only in the
military part that's also in the
civilian part yeah and and what that
clearly indicates is that Russia's
weaponization of harsh winter conditions
will pose new demands not only for
Ukraine but but also for the Western
allies for now NATO seems determined to
do what it takes but could that change
as Europe faces its own winter
challenges
[Music]
the Ukrainian soldiers should be well
equipped against the cold with hundreds
of thousands of special cold protection
jackets caps and waterproof boots from
German and Canadian inventory
it's a good start but now what Ukraine
needs most are power generators to cover
blackouts and to repair equipment for
bombed out power plants NATO has begun
to supply these
NATO allies are providing unprecedented
support
we'll find Urgent
non-lethal support including Fuel and
generators
militarily NATO is focusing its Aid on
air defense weapon systems the U.S and
France have promised to send Advanced
systems to shoot down Russian aircrafts
guided missiles and Rockets in addition
NATO has given Germany clearance to
supply the Patriot air defense system to
Ukraine
but Germany is hesitating once again
will NATO be able to help Ukraine
through the winter
and let me pass that question directly
on to Eureka and Orica Europe Germany
have shown relatively a high degree of
public support for Ukraine so far but
could that change if in fact the energy
crisis worsens here there's talk of
power outages people facing danger of
freezing
could that change the political will
it could change the political will and
of course that's what Russia is
speculating on now right now I would
like to emphasize that Germany has
actually supported Ukraine quite
substantially
um
it was often too slow or it took quite a
lot of discussions before Germany
actually did something which is which is
problematic but when you look at the
numbers and the kind of support that
Germany has provided it actually is very
substantial and we shouldn't forget that
and the support in the German population
remains high now of course you're right
we're only entering winter and the
colder it gets and the more expensive
energy becomes and the more this reaches
kind of the the the the German
households
um support could go down but right now
I'm relatively optimistic that European
support is is gonna hold uh for for the
time being and Thomas if I can come to
what we heard there in the report about
uh Germany and uh and the Patriots
Germany has in fact often been
criticized for excessive caution this is
just the latest uh in a series and yeah
well that's what I want to ask you
because we heard Secretary General
stoltenberg he was in Berlin and said
actually Germany's doing more than many
other allies it's why does Germany have
such a bad rap well I think Germany is
pretty bad when it comes to communicate
what it's doing we have a weekly list of
what has been delivered and what is
pledged to Ukraine and somehow the
government is not not really outspoken
about this they want to obscure details
sometimes or they claim for security
reasons they could be much more
outspoken I'm not sure about the reason
is maybe not to to anger Russia also but
on the other hand if you see the list
talking about self-propelled howitzers
talking about anti-aircraft cannons
talking about air defense systems
something's happening so talking about
this Patriot systems well Germany has 12
of those which are integrated into a
NATO air defense so it was a pretty bad
move from Poland to suggest to hand this
over to Ukraine so this is more polished
German infighting and not really
something to help you create
Nico if I come back to our title Russia
versus Ukraine who is better prepared to
hold out during what could be a long
winter what would be your answer my
answer is Ukraine
but we are not observers in this Ukraine
is better prepared but it will be able
to push further and to drive Russians
out if we get the support right and will
we get it right
I I think the German population would
allow the government to do more
and there are always two measurements
did we do much yes we did do much but
the other measurement is does Ukraine
have what is necessary to militarily win
this war and there we need to do more
thank you very much thanks to all of you
for being with us today and thank you to
our viewers for tuning in check out our
YouTube channel and tell us what you
think about the program pleasure to see
you goodbye
all right
[Music]
foreign
[Music]